unschätzbar ein spektakulärer juwelen
diebstahl im grünen gewölbe versetzt
nicht nur dresdens kunstfans einen
schock ohne schutz statistisch gesehen
versucht in deutschland jeden tag ein
mann seine partnerin oder ex partnerin
umzubringen
heute ist internationaler tag gegen
gewalt an frauen und ungebremst die
menge an treibhausgasen nimmt weiter zu
mit fatalen folgen für unser klima
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend hinein an
diesem montag eine neue woche schön dass
sie wieder dabei sind norbert hat
nachher den sport ein schirm und doch
von mir
es könnte durchaus der größte kunstraub
der deutschen nachkriegsgeschichte sein
eines der bekanntesten museen des landes
die schatzkammer grünes gewölbe in
dresden war heute früh ziel von
einbrechern
der wert der gestohlenen kunstschätze
ist kaum messbar
er könnte sogar in die milliarden gehen
konkret handelt es sich um diese vitrine
so soll sie vor dem einbruch ausgefüllt
mit brillanten diamanten gold und
perlenschmuck drei juwelen sets aus dem
achtzehnten jahrhundert komplett
erhalten
eigentlich galt das grüne gewölbe als
hoch gesicherte anlage wie es die diebe
trotzdem ins innere geschafft haben
stefan kelch mit weiteren einzelheiten
kurz vor 5 uhr heute morgen die täter
zerschneiden dieses massive gitter und
klettern durch ein fenster das
eigentlich einbrechern standhalten muss
alarm wird ausgelöst die wachleute sehen
überwachungsvideo zwei gestalten die
eine vitrine einschlagen eingreifen
dürfen sie nicht fünf minuten später ist
die polizei da also die liebe schon auf
der flucht
zeitgleich liegt das schloss im dunkeln
denn es brennt ein starkstrom kasten die
feuerwehr braucht lange um das feuer zu
löschen
ein zusammenhang wird nicht
ausgeschlossen wenig später brennt
unweit in einer tiefgarage ein auto
medien spekulieren es könnte das
täterfahrzeug seien gezielt hatten die
räuber eine schmuck vitrine ausgeräumt
in ihr ausgestellt waren drei berühmte
juwelen garnituren insgesamt etwa 100
einzelstücke deren wert in geld nicht
auszudrücken ist und eigentlich darin
besteht dass sie zusammen bleiben
dadurch dass diese ensemble zusammen
geblieben sind es diesen wunderbaren
kunsthistorischen und kulturhistorischen
wert gegeben hat weil das ist weltweit
einzigartig und die einzelstücke oder
sagen wir mal die der material charakter
ist längst nicht in relation zu dem was
es an bedeutung hat das sie aus holz
überliefert sind
das grüne gewölbe die schatzkammer
sachsens einen zeugen
der handwerkskunst vom barock bis zur
renaissance wie es dergleichen auf der
welt kein zweites gibt für dresdner ist
dieser diebstahl ein ungeheuerlicher
verlust ganz for sports ein riesen
verbrechen einen unserer
kulturhauptstadt und menschlich
superminis sehr schrecklich wenn sich
menschen an solchen eigentum des volkes
vergreifen nichts in dresden ist mehr
geschützt dass das grüne gewölbe
sicherheitsglas und alarmanlagen galten
bislang als unüberwindbar ein
sicherheitskonzept das heute versagt hat
ja das kann man so sagen reden wir noch
mit michael beverungen live in dresden
michael guten abend als laie staunt man
ja dann doch wie einfach es offenbar war
in so ein hochkarätiges museum 10
steigen wir haben gerade gehört die
wachen durften nicht eingreifen warum
eigentlich nicht
ja das ist die offizielle vorgehensweise
und man stellt sich tatsächlich die
frage ob es tatsächlich so einfach sein
kann scheinbar einfach das theater in
dieses schlosse rein und wieder raus
marschieren
auch wenn sie hoch professionell mit
großer krimineller energie vorgegangen
sind
die direktorin der staatlichen
kunstsammlung hat noch mal betont der
stand der sicherheitstechnik sei absolut
weltweiter stand der technik und das
sicherheitspersonal sorgen wie es gerade
gehört habe sich absolut vorbildlich
verhalten
bloß die täter sind einfach reingekommen
haben ein gitter aufgestellt ein fenster
eingeschlagen und sie sind de facto erst
innen drin bemerkt worden und die
wachleute haben sie dann bemerkt und
quasi händisch mit dem telefon die
polizei angerufen und sind dann einfach
wieder aus dem gebäude raus ob das ein
wirklich wirkungsvoller schutz
mechanismus ist daran hat er heute auch
der sächsische ministerpräsident seine
zweifel
die direktorin hat nun angekündigt dass
diese sicherheitsstandard vor dem
gesicht dieser dinge genau überprüft
werden müssen das wird in den nächsten
tagen und wochen passieren und dann wird
man sehen ob dann der stand der
sicherheitstechnik immer noch derselbe
sein kann wie heute
herzlichen dank ein spektakulärer
einbruch also der viele fragen aufwirft
mehr dazu auch gleich nach uns in einem
zdf spezial und auch online informieren
wir sie natürlich jederzeit über die
neuesten entwicklungen und hintergründe
zum kunstraub in dresden heute de und
jetzt zahlen die alarmieren es geht um
gewalt in der beziehung wobei frauen
viel häufiger betroffen sind als männer
statistisch gesehen wird in deutschland
jede stunde eine frau von ihrem partner
oder ex-partner körperlich verletzt im
vergangenen jahr mehr als 114.000 mal im
gleichen zeitraum gab es mehr als 26.000
männer die opfer wurden die häufigsten
gewalttaten waren körperverletzung und
massive bedrohung dominic purcell
berichtet maria ist 19 als sie ihre
große liebe kennen lernt ihre scheinbar
große liebe denn ihr freund fängt an sie
zu beschimpfen wenn ihnen etwas nicht
passt dann schubste er sie schließlich
steckt er zu die angst vor ihrem partner
und vater ihrer gemeinsamen tochter wird
immer größer ich habe schon in den augen
erkannt
jetzt musst du dich in acht nehmt
passiert was und wenn er einmal in
seinem film drin war sage ich mal und
mich gepackt hat hatte ich eigentlich
gar keine chancen
jede dritte frau in deutschland wird in
ihrem leben einer gewaltopfer ganz
unabhängig von ihrer sozialen schicht
oder ihrem alter
doch die wenigsten frauen zeigen ihren
partner an zu groß sind angst oder scham
gewalt gegen frauen geht uns alle an und
das ist die botschaft weil es jeden
treffen kann weil gewalt gegen frauen
allgegenwärtig ist und weil wir wollen
dass etwas getan wird dagegen und
deshalb starten wir heute die initiative
stärker als gewalt mit 120 millionen
euro und will die bundesregierung
anlaufstellen unterstützen und mehr
plätze in frauenhäusern schaffen
7000 plätze gibt es zur zeit gebraucht
würden drei mal so viele so die
ministerin
die wut ist groß warum jetzt dieses jahr
150 frauen schon abweisen müssen weil
kein platz da ist ja wir sind voll wir
haben keine warteliste weil wir brauchen
keine wir sind immer voll
und wenn ein platz frei ist er innerhalb
12 tagen spätestens wieder belegt maria
hat es geschafft sie hat ihren damaligen
freund angezeigt und für immer verlassen
nun berichtet sie über ihr schicksal und
unterstützt damit andere frauen sich zu
wehren
ins ausland das ergebnis der
kommunalwahl in hongkong ist da und es
ist überwältigend für die demokratie
bewegung die seit monaten dort auf die
straße geht ein klarer sieg für deren
kandidaten
sie haben dem china treuen regierungs
blog die meisten sitze in den
bezirksräten abgenommen
die menschen in hongkong waren so
zahlreich zu dieser wahl gegangen wie
nie zuvor und roller ist in hongkong
kurz nach 12 uhr mittags gehen die
hongkonger geschäftsleute auf die straße
es sind keine schwarzgekleideten
maskierten jugendlichen
es ist der protest aus der mitte der
gesellschaft sie haben neuen mut
geschöpft nach dem wahlsieg der
demokratiebewegung
diese wahl macht einen entscheidenden
unterschied war jetzt jeder weiß dass
eine große mehrheit die
demokratiebewegung unterstützt aber die
regierung akzeptiert und interessiert
das nicht
und dann kommt der auftritt von regina
ehm
sie ist eine peking treue hongkonger
politikerin die die demonstranten immer
wieder als aufrührer beschimpft hat sie
wird zeigen hongkong hat chinas
autorität zu akzeptieren egal wie
gewählt wurde
ich bin sehr enttäuscht es ist sehr laut
hier ich rede später
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die sorgen gerade gesehen haben ist eine
bunte
african politik und michael sind wir
meister die wut enthält vorstand statt
explosiv ausbauen
am abend stehen sich die polizei und die
demonstranten vor der polytechnischen
universität gegenüber vor einer woche
gab es hier heftige kämpfe drinnen haben
sich immer noch einige studenten
verschanzt
wir wollen die polizei unter druck
setzen damit sie unsere freunde
rauslassen
am tag eins nach dem sieg für die
demokratie bewegung zeigt die
staatsmacht weiter härte
in rumänien bleibt klaus johannis
präsident bei der stichwahl kam der
bürgerliche amtsinhaber auf rund zwei
drittel der stimmen und konnte sich
damit deutlich gegen seine
sozialdemokratische kontrahenten
durchsetzen
johannes gehört der deutschen minderheit
in rumänien an und will das land wieder
auf einen pro europäischen kurs bringen
die eu fordert einen stärkeren kampf
gegen die korruption eine woche noch bis
zur weltklimakonferenz in madrid da
kommt heute diese warnung der
wissenschaftler
die menge an treibhausgasen in der
atmosphäre nimmt weiter zu und erreicht
einen neuen höchststand das sagt die
un-wetterbehörde gleich dazu mehr erst
ein kurzer blick von delia thomas darauf
was treibhausgase sind und wie sie sich
in der erdatmosphäre auswirken
sie sind das größte problem im unteren
bereich der atmosphäre die spurengase
kohlendioxid methan und lachgas
zusammen kommen sie dort zwar nur auf
eine relativ niedrige konzentration sind
aber besonders klimarelevant denn mit
ihrer struktur halten sie die wärme in
unserer atmosphäre anders gesagt je mehr
von diesen gasen ausgestoßen werden
desto schneller steigen die temperaturen
auf der erde
besonders folgenschwer für unser klima
ist das kohlendioxid also co2 66 der
erderwärmung gehen darauf zurück dann
kommt das folgendes gas methan mit knapp
17 prozent
und schließlich lachgas mit immer noch
rund sechs prozent
die konzentration der treibhausgase
nimmt also weiter zu und trotz
intensiver diskussionen ums klima
weltweit ist keine wende in sicht
über die neuen daten der
un-wetterbehörde berichtet marco sehen
können wir die treibhausgase in der
atmosphäre nicht aber messen sie nehmen
stetig zu heizen das klima auf der erde
an
trotz aller politischer ambitionen und
ankündigungen nach neuesten zahlen der
weltorganisation für meteorologie
erreichte die konzentration von
kohlendioxid 2018 den stand von 4 107,8
ppm also teilen pro million bei der
präsentation der werte in genf deutliche
worte wir haben bei der kohlendioxid
konzentration schon wieder einen rekord
gebrochen
schon vor zwei jahren hatten wir die 400
ppm marke gerissen die als kritisch
betrachtet wird und dieses wachstum der
kohlendioxid konzentration geht immer
weiter
dennoch ist der ausstoß von
treibhausgasen bei weitem nicht gestoppt
im gegenteil weltweit steigt er an
wissenschaftler warnen so kann der
klimawandel nicht gebremst werden
die weltgemeinschaft hat sich auf das
ziel festgelegt die globale erwärmung
auf deutlich unter zwei grad besser noch
15 grad zu begrenzen und um diese ziele
zu erreichen muss man es schaffen die
emission au bis ungefähr mitte des
jahrhunderts auf null zurückzufahren
unsere rechnungen zeigen dass das
durchaus geht es ist letztlich aber ein
freies politischen willens der
klimawandel wartet nicht ein weiteres
warnsignal eine woche vor dem start der
weltklimakonferenz in madrid
die bundesregierung hat besorgt auf
berichte reagiert nach denen in china
bis zu einer million uiguren in lagern
eingesperrt sind sie fordert experten
der vereinten nationen müsse
ungehinderter zugang gewährt werden
zuvor waren geheimdokumente der
chinesischen regierung an die
öffentlichkeit gekommen
sie belegen ganz offenbar wie die
menschen systematisch verfolgt verhaftet
und umerzogen werden
die uiguren sind eine muslimische
minderheit in der chinesischen
bevölkerung die seit jahren für ihre
unabhängigkeit kämpft einen monat nach
dem in england 39 tote migranten in
einem lkw gefunden wurden hat jetzt der
fahrer ein teil geständnis gegenüber dem
londoner strafgericht abgelegt er
bekannte sich schuldig der beihilfe zur
illegalen einwanderung
zum vorwurf der fahrlässigen tötung
sagte er nichts
mittlerweile wird immer mehr über das
schicksal der gestorbenen vietnamesen
bekannt und über die schmuggelrouten
quer über den globus andreas stamm alles
was im hafen von perth lied an 39 tote
erinnert vermutlich erstickt vor rund
vier wochen in einem kühllaster nichts
habe sich seitdem geändert erzählt janet
leigh
sie wohnt in der nähe des
containerhafens lkws kommen und mit
ihnen die flüchtlinge mit der wind pässe
aus den verschiedensten ländern in
unseren garten oder auch nur die
fotoseiten wir melden dass der polizei
und den behörden und die sagen darf die
pässe einfach weg
tagelang hatte die britische polizei
ende oktober gerätselt dann stand fest
die toten im anhänger der per fähre aus
dem belgischen zeebrügge kam stammt aus
nordvietnam unter ihnen boitin um die 19
jährige wollte nach england dort
arbeiten damit die familie schulden
zurückzahlen kann
sie schickte bilder aus deutschland von
der schmuggelroute quer durch europa
dann hörte die mutter nichts mehr von
ihm
ich will nur dass der britische
botschafter meine schwester zurückbringt
wir wollen sie auf unserem friedhof
bestatten
die mutter hat tagelang nicht gesprochen
nun sind sie vom schreien ihrer tochter
bittet um gnade und vergebung
fluchtgrund armut die die gehen endeten
oft in nagelstudios in europa alle fest
in vietnamesischer hand erzählen sie das
geld das sie schicken sei
überlebenswichtig für die flüchtlinge
eine reise in ein leben voller
ausbeutung oft über die route die auch
die 39 nahmen zwei autostunden nördlich
von paris im wald ein camp für
vietnamesen die letzte station bevor es
in einen lkw anhänger richtung england
geht und ein letztes gebet dass alles
gut geht zumindest diesmal
heftige stürme heftiger regen in süd
europa mindestens sieben menschen sind
ums leben gekommen
betroffen waren in den vergangenen tagen
südfrankreich und norditalien
und jetzt sind die unwetter nach
griechenland weiter gezogen hier wurden
zwei touristen tot aufgefunden ihr
segelboot war offenbar während des
sturms gekannt hat in vielen orten gibt
es schwere schäden hunderte häuser
stehen unter wasser autos wurden
weggespült nach erdrutschen musste die
autobahn zwischen athen und der
hafenstadt patras im westen des landes
gesperrt werden das wetter bei uns haben
wir gleich erstmal schauen wir auf alles
sportliche hier und da fangen wir heute
mit der champions league an
da tritt bayern münchen morgen abend in
belgrad an und will die erfolgsserie
unter trainer hansi flick unbedingt
fortsetzen
die mission beim spiel gegen roter stern
heißt gruppensieg die reise beginnt mit
warten fast eine stunde verzögert sich
der abflug der bayern heute mittag wegen
nebels erst dann geht es los richtung
belgrad mit klarem ziel nach bisher vier
champions league siegen in vier spielen
haben es ganz gut vorbereitet wollen
natürlich auch da sehr gutes spiel
machen wie wir das jetzt in der letzten
in der letzten wochen gemacht haben mit
neu coach hansi flick haben die bayern
ihre dominanz wiedergefunden 8 zu 0 tore
aus den letzten beiden bundesliga
spielen gegen dortmund und düsseldorf
geben viel selbstvertrauen für die
partie gegen serbiens meister ein sieg
und die bayern während sicher erster der
gruppe b und die erfolgsserie von hansi
flick hätte weiter bestand
ja was die champions league in europa
ist die copa libertadores in südamerika
und da ist der finalsieger cr flamengo
von zehntausenden trio begeistert
empfangen worden
verkehrschaos am zuckerhut eine
rot-schwarze ist jubelmeer ja und der
lastwagen mit brasiliens fußball helden
er brauchte für die 25 kilometer lange
party spreche über vier stunden
wenig grund zum jubeln dagegen haben
derzeit die berliner hertha und ihr
coach ante covic vier niederlagen in
folge
der trainerstuhl wackelt bedenklich der
tag nach der 0 4-klatsche in augsburg
die berliner profis angeführt von
trainer georgi über seine
weiterbeschäftigung diskutieren sie bei
der hertha er selbst bleibt gelassen ich
glaube dass ich der unwichtigste person
ihr bin was meinen eigenen befinden
betrifft sondern hier geht es um uns als
verein der schlechte lauf der berliner
spricht gegen eine weiterbeschäftigung
des trainers der hofft und will kämpfen
durchhalteparolen in erster linie muss
man der mannschaft vermitteln dass man
kerzengerade steht und das mache ich ja
permanent und dass man nicht eingelenkt
wie lange er dazu noch gelegenheit hat
entscheidet sich in den nächsten tagen
wir bleiben dran das was von mir dann
genau wird mit kostbarste kunst hat
diese sendung begonnen und so endet sie
auch es geht um die vierte überhaupt
jemals auf der welt gedruckte bibel
entstanden 1462 in mainz die heilige
schrift in zwei bänden preziosen aus
pergament schmuckvoll verziert in
hamburg kam das buch der bücher heute
unter den hammer erwartet bei der
auktion wurde eine million euro
und so geschah es vor anderthalb stunden
zahlt ein privater schweizer sammler
noch 50.000 euro mehr also 1.050.000 für
wirklich wertvolle lektüre was mit der
bibel jetzt geschieht und ob sie für
alle zu sehen sein wird ist offen
wir haben den wetterbericht gleich nach
dieser sendung und ich habe noch den
hinweis auf heute journal für sie um 21
uhr 45 morgen freut sich hier barbara
hahlweg auf sie aber jetzt erst mal das
zdf spezial zum spektakulären kunstraub
in dresden mit andreas klinner
ich danke für ihr interesse und im namen
des gesamten heute 19 teams in allen
einen angenehmen haben
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter neuer regen
erreichte uns mit einem tief was derzeit
noch auf dem atlantik liegt und
allmählich richtung deutschland wandert
ja und dabei kommt viel regen mit und
auch wind morgen gibt es etwas regen
das sieht man hier an diesen blauen
streifen das wird aber nicht viel sein
er sprühregen in der nacht bildet sich
erst mal dichter nebel aus ganz im
westen da kann es mal tröpfeln und auch
in schleswig holstein
das ist eigentlich nur sprühregen also
die großen mengen sind es nicht und die
temperaturen dazu die sinken auf 0 grad
am alpenrand und 7 grad am niederrhein
morgen im tagesverlauf erreichen uns
diese wolken mit dem sprühregen also
gelegentlich tritt wird es mal aber oft
bleibt es trocken und im süden da kann
sich mal die sonne zeigen und auch nach
osten hin
die temperaturen erreichen dabei sechs
grad an der ostsee und 14 grad im
südwesten hier also ziemlich mit die
nächsten tage werden ziemlich nass und
windig das geht schon am mittwoch los
und der wind kommt dabei kräftig aus
südlichen richtungen 7 bis 14 grad die
höchsten werte am donnerstag sieht es
ähnlich aus und am freitag wird es
kühler und in den mittelgebirgen kommt
sogar schnee dazu damit wünsche ich
ihnen ein schöner abend